we might be drunk we
might be drunk as long as we
are hanging out you know we might be
drunk
raise a glass let's talk [ __ ] pet peeves
wrecks and a bit
maybe trump we might be drunk
yeah yo i feel like i always started you
started all right
i don't want to hog it thanks for uh
thanks for you you're very uh
your selfless guy well i try to you know
be any equality
[Music]
um well you were asking me right before
this and i was like let's
save it because i like to just talk
whatever we're talking about sure you
don't know what do not disturb is on
your phone well i said hey
are you gonna go airplane mode you said
do not disturb do not disturb all day
what does that mean well i miss a lot of
calls because i do this
it just doesn't alert it doesn't your
phone doesn't ring okay
and you don't see the text but i just
get to the text when i see the tech ah
i love that it doesn't light up exactly
oh i like that
save some battery well it saves battery
but it's also you just like
every time your phone vibrates you're
like distracted
this way you can kind of like be like
i'll deal with it all at once i like
that
i like that okay what do i push you just
do this thing here
you swipe down and then you do the
little moon oh the moon
i never knew what the moon did i thought
it was some kind of night mode or some
[ __ ]
it's kind of his night mode and you were
saying before this that you got
you got weirded out by our friend
salaccus you helped him pick up his kid
and that why i don't know why that
weirded you out well me and fat sally
were hitting a diner and he was like oh
[ __ ] it's 3
10 or whatever 2 30. i got to go pick up
my kid and i was like ah
i'll see you later and he was like well
it's two blocks away in hell's kitchen i
was like all right
so i walk over there and it's just this
you know public school with
a hundred parents outside and they're
all like billy
timmy and the kids running their arms i
was like i gotta get out of here
it was too much it was too wholesome and
you know his kids are so cute i guess
that's better than the opposite we were
like i gotta do this more often
yeah exactly that's weird that it's just
parents
yeah i don't know it made me think about
my parents and then i was like do i want
a kid
and then i took one home but uh yeah
i don't know it was just it was too
feely and then
his kid had another kid with him and he
had chocolate all over his mouth and
hold he was cute and the kid wouldn't
shut
up and i had to hold one of their hands
and we went to a bodega and sound like
he's bought him a
snickers and they were like oh my god it
was it was too much dude candy to a kid
you see why these pedophiles go straight
to the candy they love it it works they
really
candy what is it with kids by the way
with like chocolate and
it's just they cannot hit their the
inside of the bag it's like all
always like a chocolate beard that's
true yeah i mean it looks like they're
all eating ass
and it's a problem but i think they're
there what do you call it their uh
hand-eye coordination isn't as skilled
we have years and years of hours
of dick that's why you can also head
kids yes they're
terrible with the blocking that's true
yeah
wouldn't it be fun this is a dark open
right yeah that's true well i was about
to get darker but wouldn't it be fun to
just i feel like how many kids do you
think you could take before they took
you down
i'm talking like five-year-old how many
i think i could take them all
i'm talking about but it's an unlimited
amount just coming at you
you hit them once so they go down i
think yeah i mean you could kick to the
face it's that perfect height
yeah for sure so you think like 100. i
think if
if no one really got hurt it'd be like a
fun video game type thing
yes just to see how many you could pull
off oh man you could throw them
you could throw them into each other you
could spin them and hit
he hit all the other ones oh my god i
feel like conor mcgregor for just a
minute
yes exactly it's kind of like when you
play kid jeopardy and you're like i'm a
genius
what's two plus two you're like oh my
god i'm killing this
i brought a fun one in today look at
that what the hell is this it looks like
a 40.
it's a it's a natural wine wow
the guy at the store called it very
drinkable oh
it's uh i guess i need liquor if you're
opposed to what
but he said it just it goes down really
easy wow it looks like a soda it looks
like an old school soda
yeah it's natural so the hangover's not
as bad and he said it's good stuff so
let's give it a go man and a pop top
like a like a coke
oh my god this is very exciting you're
introducing me all these new drugs wait
i'm introducing
myself to it i don't know oh boy oh boy
oh it looks like wine
we'll see if it tastes like it's a nice
bold red
i'm gonna give this a a sniff you know
who's a bold red
christina hendricks med oh
man i'd like to roam those hills
there we go cheers we look like
a couple old italian men with these
little wine glasses you know
oh that's pretty good it's like bitter
too oh
that's got a kick that's us in a couple
years
right there yeah i don't know i would
refer to this as very drinkable what do
you think
it's good don't get me wrong i'm just
saying the guy did look like an
alcoholic
yeah yeah this feels like a like a down
on your luck
in a gutter drink all right but
gutter wine yeah gutter wine that's a
that's one name for a wine great name
for a wine we could do something with
that
yeah gutter wine that's like
coppola just has the wine now that's
like his thing oh really
yeah that's cause i mean it's crazy we
were talking about last
week like the maybe it was the patreon
whatever but uh
you know how you kind of go out on your
terms like that's what tarantino is
doing but
it's like he can't make [ __ ] i know
isn't that so weird the guy
you know the godfather probably one of
the best gangster movies if not the best
of all time
cannot get a gig in hollywood it's all
out of whack
by the way get on the patreon because
you're the patreon is us after the epps
so we've got like
you know tons of alcohol in us so it's a
different show
it gets more uh real yeah oh yeah
oh you gotta pay extra for that right i
mean you thought beating up kids was
something
wait till you see the patreon we uh yeah
so go to patreon.com we might be drunk
pod
and give us a review on the itunes
that's pretty good very good i bet it
gets more drinkable i
think you're right as we go yeah i'm
into it i think the first sip is not
supposed to be like i can have a whole
bottle
i think that that comes right i hate to
be a coos but
you put two ice cubes in there i bet
it's i bet it helps
yeah well just keeps it cause it's so
cold right now it helps can't get behind
i can't get behind the ice cubes and
wine i've never
done it but this i feel like would do it
this is gonna segue into my wreck can i
give you
i just re-watched sideways oh my god i
love sideways it's like the perfect
movie to watch anytime yes alexander
payne
yeah yeah so good paul giamatti is great
and the the hymn and thomas hayden
church
like chemistry it's amazing it's so it's
so real
yeah it is because you do have that
friend where you're like
i'm just friends with him because we
grew up together he drives me nuts
i love him but he's not a good human
being right
and like everyone has that friend yes
you know and like
yeah the way he just couldn't turn it
off like he's like literally he's on his
[ __ ]
you know this is supposed to be like a
quiet yeah like just try some lines and
he's like
i need to [ __ ] everyone like like
literally the scene in the end where
like the heavy waitress he's he's like i
bet she'd be two tons of fun he's like
can't we just
eat a meal i know and then the other
guy's going through a divorce or a book
he's like he can't get his book sold or
something's going on giamatti like he's
waiting to hear
yeah i was like oh [ __ ] that's such a
relatable phone call
where you're on with your agent and
they're just like for whatever reason
this one's not gonna go and i'm like oh
[ __ ] how many of those that we heard too
many
oh my god yeah it's so true i mean we're
on youtube folks
but yeah it but that is how did he think
of that you know you hear a premise and
we go oh that could be a bit or a
director
or a writer's like that's a movie that
premise is a movie this
it's just so loosey-goosey like two
friends on a wine retreat kind of thing
it doesn't really have bones there but
yet
pain was so good he's like no no this is
going to be good but it's mapped out
like you keep like you know it doesn't
feel like it does
but things keep happening like i watch
it differently each time i watch it
because it's like the perfect comedy but
it also has like those scenes where
you're like wow this is like
moving some of these yes so there's that
there's those parts like we haven't seen
it sorry just given some spoilers here
but there's the part where
you know he tells her
basically he slit he let he sees that
woman he likes maya
yeah he lets it slip that you know as
he's banging her good friend
right that he's getting married so
there's like things where she's like you
[ __ ] lied to me
there's like steaks raised he lies
through about the book there's
little things yeah that you're like oh
[ __ ] is he gonna get
caught for this so they they build the
there's still like a plot
yeah even though it doesn't feel like it
though does it feel like that lucia
movie
yeah you know those comics you see where
they're saying brilliant [ __ ] but the
technique is hidden you know it's not
like
yeah but they're still killing like a
patrice o'neal exactly
exactly and that movie is like that
where there's an arc and an a story and
a b
story and act one act two but you don't
feel it and when [ __ ] happens it almost
surprised you because that's the type of
movie you can lose yourself in where
you're like this
i love a movie that makes you laugh one
minute and it makes you like oh [ __ ]
that was like a great
yeah it was like a great monologue
there's a whole thing i mean it's like
kind of cheesy but it
works because giamatti is such a good
actor when he just has this whole
monologue about why he loves pinot noir
right it's like well it's you know it's
not what people don't like the slightest
thing it doesn't work it's not respected
by people the way this is
yeah oh that's how you feel about
yourself
i mean it's like i mean it's a it's an
obvious thing but it's just like
i i was like oh it's just like so many
lines like that that are
that just rock and it's great because
it's one of those movies where
i bet it was written for him and mine
because yeah he's so good at it
that was his breakout totally break well
he was in american splendor
private parts too yeah well he was he
was i think known as a really good actor
american splendor
great movie yeah but like i don't think
he was known as like
yeah oh it's like a like well this guy's
box office right now right
i think he's just known as a really good
actor yeah almost like a hoffman
yeah yeah like the ugly guy but he's so
talented
but i feel like this movie let him be
let him show showcase how great he
really is and
and he's incredible incredible and
thomas hayden church was
all i knew was wings remember he was
loyal or lyle or lowell and wings
have you ever seen wings no no oh my god
tampon with wings
uh maxi pad but yeah he he it was a
horrible sitcom that i watched every
episode it came on after cheers and
that's the only reason
it got any loading great lead in cheers
number one show on tv
wings event or cheers moved wings got
cancelled
seinfeld went in after cheers and that's
a safe sign holy [ __ ]
fun fact damn i've read every uh book on
seinfeld
i'm sure yeah just because the show is
such it's such an unheard of kind of
show
it's so innovative and weird and it was
bombing for for four seasons it was
bombing and then it got on after cheers
and it saved them
no they would never let a show breathe
out like that anymore no way no way then
it becomes the best show of all the show
is like a good
drinkable wine yes sometimes it needs a
minute to breathe
here here anything i mean there's a lot
of comics so it's like i feel like
didn't find themselves
until a certain point and then they like
kind of turn that corner oh you could
even say that about like louis ck oh for
sure
rock yes rock his old stuff you're like
all right he's just like an angry guy
whatever and then he just
clicked yeah i mean there's that old
story about like louie and sarah
silverman and a couple other guys david
tell went to go see him at caroline's
like he's been on the road for like two
years we haven't seen him
headlines caroline's they're all in the
back like
what is this this is new it was bring
the pain they'd never seen it they saw
it live and they're like
who's this guy i could never do this so
it changed the game
you've heard that story with martin
lawrence about that no oh my god though
did you say this you didn't say this
uh did i say this there matt yeah who i
don't know what is it so
basically chris rock was like this funny
guy great writer you know he had a
little stint on snl
so he's getting some heat but he's a
comic at heart he's on the road he's
like i should do more black rooms this
guy opens for him
blows him off stage yeah martin lawrence
a young martin lawrence
and he was like oh my god i can't follow
this and then he
he like changed his life where he's like
i gotta start walking around that's
where all that [ __ ] came from like
pacing the stage because he was like i
have to move
rock had a little sam kinnison in him oh
like kind of holding the room and that
that booming voice
totally although you see rock at a
comedy club he's just kind of talking
the bits out but yeah yeah
it's funny that like you know what's the
worst thing about drinking is
you're with your friend and you're like
he's already told me this story we
literally built the podcast around that
it's a speaking show and i'm like i
think i've told mark this i can't
and then we definitely did right don't
forgive us at home for this
please tell me what i've told you
because i'm back at you because i do
okay people do it it's embarrassing
because i've been hanging out with guys
and i'm like
but it's my fault too because i'm like i
don't remember until halfway through
sometimes
right right but i told you that on here
yeah ah
it might have been a patreon all right
all right well we got i mean look
guys it's like you can't win it's like
some people are mad we're not drunk
enough other people
are mad we repeat what are you gonna do
yeah it's kind of adorable my
my girlfriend has a pod now and she's
like i'm getting all this uh these mean
comments i'm like whoo
buckle up [ __ ] it's about to get way
worse
this is this is just the the beginning
if you called her a [ __ ]
that's the name it's a part about
driving called buckle up [ __ ]
and uh yeah you just start speaking in
common you're like another unfunny woman
but yeah so she's like this guy was kind
of mean to me just i'm like are you
kidding
me oh my god pull out a scroll i got a
great one today that i had to post
because it was like
another hetero man uh well let me wait
let me read it because i hate that
screen shots
some of these make me laugh like of
course
it's so funny that we've gone so far
like uh progressive that it becomes now
you're judging me based on my skin
my sexual orientation my you know all
this [ __ ] and you're like what are we
doing
with me bombing on morning tv which i
think are always funny yeah
so uh i post on tick tock it does a
shitload of views on tick tock
oh yeah but then you know you get the
people i always like to lead in with
like
bombing so people are like if it's
positive they're like you're not bombing
but if it's bad they're like yeah you
[ __ ] yeah you're bombing you stink
right so this guy writes oh yes the
forgettable experiences of a white
hetero hetero man is comedy uh
i thought that's what we did here i
thought we were observational comedians
i know
that was making the mundane funny yeah
exactly
jesus christ what are you gonna do uh
yeah yeah i mean there's psychos
everywhere
but it's kind of i kind of enjoy it i
think it's funny i don't look for it but
every once in a while i'm like let me
see and i'm like oh it's kind of funny i
should enjoy it more but
i i i it's ridiculous how do you know it
is yeah i don't know but that guy's
walking the streets and you could bump
in him at whole foods and and be like oh
sorry man he's like
oh no problem then he goes home he's
like white hetero man that's like bugs
baby what is does he need every story to
be like
and that was uh and that was one about
slavery and you're like does everything
have to be murderous
i agree i agree i'm with you not
everything has to be but not all comedy
has to be about someone's plight some
there's
escapist comedy of course i mean nate
bergatzi is doing very well
on netflix and he sells out everywhere i
think we're we're kind of craving a
little bit of just like
well not everyone's comedy is for
everybody well that too that too but
we got into this weird thing where i
don't know the world's all [ __ ] up but
like
ted bundy's got a dock and then we gotta
have another talk about dahmer like the
15
we love murder now we always loved it
but now it's like
so and type true crime is is bigger than
ever
what do you think it is why michael
jackson's got to have a documentary like
we know he [ __ ] kids do we need to like
have the scene where the guy's butthole
gets opened up and all that well they
know it's going to get
a lot of eyeballs because it's michael
jackson for that one that's
it's obvious when they made that and
also it's like they're those people who
are like well i love michael jackson
but let me see uh how i feel about this
it's it's those are tough with michael
jackson because we're complicit
right because that's why it takes so
long to turn on people like that because
it's like we all [ __ ] love his music
yeah i mean i still hear it at target
oh my god i heard like billie jean the
other day and i was like it's a good
song man
great song i mean the guy's talented you
can eat it
yeah beat it yeah that's what he did but
yeah it's uh it's just weird because
like we like craved it for a while
it was almost kind of like i feel like
we were going very
we got to love everybody and body
positivity and don't shame so then you
almost have to like even it out with uh
hey here's a pedophile
let's all hate him that's what it feels
like it is
i do feel guilty watching it sometimes
because it's like
you forget that they're real people oh
i'm literally watching like a dateline
episode and her body was never
discovered and i'm like past the pad top
you know we're so disconnected from it
completely i mean that's all social
media is like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] and you're like my mom might see
this you know you psycho relax
what's the beef i'm a human being it's
it's weird like those murder docs are
like
they are addictive too yeah i think part
of it is like we all in our heart
like want to be part of like there's
something so satisfying about piecing
something together
too i think that's why people love the
forensic files is like i love it
well like that they use science to solve
a murder so like yeah that's cool it's
like in the end there's justice like
that but then you have like ones like
unsolved myth
yeah and that's what i don't love i
don't like it you get no clothes no
closure
i want an orgasm at the end i want that
uh that dead body to jizz off
it is it is it's [ __ ] without coming
it is yeah
yeah where'd the condom go i don't know
but yeah i don't like that i want it to
i want to have the the button on it it's
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] without coming
because uh
there's a less
[Music]
i life it but write it down write it
down that could be something
ah but uh dude i love the uh although i
do there are some unsolved ones like
[ __ ]
you know it was a pretty good one on hbo
murder at uh middle beach
love code that was good because we don't
need to know it like if the journey is
that incredible
right right i don't really care about
the ending because you learn so much
about him
and his struggle made by the son
who lost the parent he lost his mother
and there were some weird parts of that
oh the whole ponzi scheme part was so
weird and also there was a part where uh
this old lady next door was like i saw a
gentleman enter the house in a ski mask
and like first off maybe we should refer
to him as a gentleman
you know yeah that's uh exactly what
happened
but uh the fact that there were like a
lot of red flags like that where like
you just saw a dude enter
in a ski mask right it seemed very
clearly to be the dad
i felt like that if you're just like if
every time you bring it up
you're like he's like so who murdered
mom he's like i thought we were having a
sandwich
yeah yeah right i know you can't just
there are people like that though like
don't you find that like when you talk
try to talk about like really heavy
stuff with your dad that it's
oh it's it's hard what if it's a murder
i feel like you should at least be able
to ask once
yeah maybe your mom got murdered you
know
yeah you got to bring it up yeah it's a
big matzo ball hanging out there so i
get it
but man that is uh heavy stuff because
it's also
you got to remember there's cameras and
lights in the living room so it's not
just like hey dad what's up with this or
hey mom what's going on here it's like
hey here's my crew
uh we're gonna put a little makeup on
you okay where's mom
you know it's a it's kind of a lot with
production there
it is a lot yeah but he was going like
secret mic and that [ __ ] like he was
showing up
yeah you know like with the camera guy
outside miked up like you're wearing a
wire
against your dad ah isn't that great i
mean that's got to be [ __ ] up just to
even
even if you don't think he did it but
there's a possibility that kind of
that's gotta [ __ ] your life up a little
bit
so you know jason katz my buddy i think
you filmed your special he directed i
got this
yeah there you go jason yeah great guy
so i'm this this is this is a little
nugget about me i'm so disconnected with
my parents
and my dad is having some health issues
so i asked
jason in like a sad text
to interview my parents about me so when
they die
i'm gonna watch it wow how [ __ ] up is
that
i've never told anybody you can't just
ask him
like what ask them yeah why can't you
just i mean i understand
videotaping it for when they move on or
whatever but you don't want to
you don't want to just be like what do
you think of my comedy ah
it's too weird is it beyond your comedy
or is it mostly
it's yeah it's everything it's the whole
life it's the
the whole relationship and nothing
happened i wasn't diddled or anything
but it's just
uh that stresses me out just hearing it
well i feel in my weird
twisted logic i'm like this is i'll get
something out of this
this is a this is a move in the right
direction is it going to
uh in any way play into the eulogy are
you going to watch it before you
eulogize nah nah i'll probably watch in
like
30 years really yeah sit on it for a
while let it build some interest
really yeah i don't want to i don't know
maybe maybe i'll never watch it i
definitely think like
it is weird like dads of that generation
or not
i mean look we're probably it's probably
like they're
too closed off and we might be too open
i think that might be the problem
we have to be open just to it's our
overcompensation
but it's our generation too i mean it's
like they don't like we're like we're
the tick-tock generation
of these kids who are just like i mean
maybe we're a little older than that but
like
those people just literally on like so i
was thinking about this the other day
and you're like how much more
it's only going to move more forward i
know like how far is it going to be it's
literally going to be like a kid spread
eagle like here are my balls
and uh i think they're weird yeah
what do you think send me photos of your
balls we can compare yeah you're right
it's gonna go there
but i just think about you know like
there is
it is tough like i love my dad but i
definitely feel like yeah there's a
there is a there's a wall there's a wall
i think of just people of his generation
i don't even blame him like
i think there was a much bigger wall
with his dad so for him to be where he
is
yes is is huge yeah yeah i agree
and uh my dad's got the most [ __ ] up
childhood so i don't i don't fault him i
don't blame him
uh military guy uh tortured weirdo guy
so like tortured in the military
no no as a kid oh geez back to back i
was like was your [ __ ] dad mccain
waterboarded jesus christ yeah i know he
uh
the waterboard was nothing compared to
this video he's gonna make for his son
i know i know it's brutal he's gonna
hate it but uh my mom
texts me like do you know this guy jason
i was like oh yeah i probably should
have prepped you
that's something you guys prepped i
didn't want to text them that's a whole
nother thing you hate con
you hate interaction you ate
any confrontation probably more than
anyone i've ever met because i don't
like it but you hate it so much more
than that i hate it
yeah i feel like i i really don't like
it but i will do it
yeah you'll do it you'll do it but you
really like you just can't do it why is
that
i don't know i think well this is
getting into a what is this
uh oprah here but uh you're interesting
you're an interesting guy
well i think it's because my dad was he
had like a
short fuse like he would just turn like
where you know you're petting a cat and
you're like oh this is fun
and the cat's like my dad was like that
you know like we were like whoa
and it was so scary as a as a little kid
that uh i just don't want to don't want
to wake the beast yeah the worst part
was his urine
i got really bad no it's on my couch to
market
dude i i can't believe i mean i think a
lot
my dad was like my parents didn't hit me
like i've said this on the pod before
but like as bad as the guy was like the
wrist grabbing you're like oh
you're hurting me but no he my parents
were all about like
you were very disappointed it's like oh
yeah very white liberal
uh which also stings the disappointed is
worse than like
come on you piece of [ __ ] get in your
room you're like oh man i gotta get my
[ __ ] together
but yeah i'm fascinated like
yeah i get it like you're scared i mean
we all have that thing
with comics we're like look let's be
real any entertainer has that
need liked sure you have that thing
where you're like i need it
so bad i need it's so weird to me that
like
people will say things to me like you're
it's amazing what you do to be on stage
and i'm just like
no it's amazing what you do to be a
well-adjusted person
the stage is easy being being a normal
well-adjusted member society takes so
much more work yeah yeah you're in a
cubicle all day dealing with other
people all day
answering phones talking to people
that's a nightmare
i'm so much more comfortable on stage
than i am at like a social gathering oh
yeah that's one way one place we bond
well also
the stage there's no stakes really if
you bomb it's kind of like
i'll i'll bounce back yeah if you bomb
socially that
just lingers something that's going to
be talked about
for such a long period of time but it
does say something weird about us that
we have like there's something about
being a comic that i think is like we're
saying
what we felt we weren't allowed to say
yes like growing up we couldn't say this
to our family so we're more comfortable
saying this
to strangers you know so but the social
thing is tough because
you're you bomb socially they're like
this guy's weird this guy's off this
guy's an idiot you
bomb on stage it's like he had a bad set
it's not really you
as a human being as a person so you can
walk away going i tried some new i
[ __ ] it up i riffed something stupid i
said
it wasn't funny i'll go do it again
tomorrow but the the
party you bomb at the party or with your
girlfriend's parents or whatever the
hell it is
they go this guy is unfit this guy's
unwell this guy's a little nutty
i need new friends you need new friends
you got a new crowd i need a new group
of friends
for those friends you got to move out of
town i left new orleans and i was like
oh i got to get out of here you know
just go to a new place new people you
had one bad dinner you're like
new york yeah i got a one-way ticket
it's true yeah like you still live here
you're around all your high school
all year it's weird yeah it is i can't
imagine it's weird
um yeah it's tough i mean there's those
people like
time is like the thing i don't you can't
get back like time is everything
to me now because i i have very little
free time now
because i i'm on the road every weekend
so then i have like three days here a
week usually
yeah same one of them is usually like
panicking about leaving the next day
yeah
getting all my [ __ ] in order maybe
laundry or like packing you ever heard
that palace act joke
what's his job great palace michael
palsack check him out he is joking he's
like west coast phil hanley
yeah yeah he's handsome he's cute he's a
great joke he's like oh god i'm
so stressed out i got a six a.m flight
in two weeks oh
and you're like [ __ ] sums up my whole
personality
damn that's a great comedy joke great
line yeah
flight in two weeks two weeks it's so
true you just it consumes you you're
like oh [ __ ]
i got some sleep tonight but in two
weeks i'm [ __ ] i had to wake up for a
doctor's appointment this morning
at like 7 30 a.m and it's just like if i
wake up at 7 30 in the morning like
you can't complain about that to a
normal person but to a comic they're
like oh you because they
comics just get that we're like yeah i
go to bed at three no matter
yes exactly there's no way around that
no way around it's so funny
i'm a three a.m man myself and that's me
like go
i gotta go to bed now it's 2 30 put
yourself in bed
and the anxiety keeps kicking up every
30 minutes or so you're like
[ __ ] my heart beats faster and faster
yeah i do a lot of like every hour
i wake up to piss and i'm just like god
people old people are always like
wait till you get older i'm like how
much more can i piss
i know right you do peel on i had to
stretch the bladder as a kid i was a
bedwetter
so my i had two [ __ ] my dad again
old school no more drinks after six so
after 6 p.m i was off
liquid in new orleans that heat yes
and then two was uh oh
when you have to pee he's like i'm not
gonna let you go cause i want you to
stretch the bladder
so that's like when the parents make the
baby cry yeah they don't help and
they're like for your own good
they did that with your [ __ ] penis
yeah i guess so yeah it was tough but
we'd play edward 40 hands did you play
that in college
what is that edward you tape the
40s to your hands two 40s your hands so
you can't pee cause you can't gonna do
your zipper obviously you got two 40s in
your hand
so you had to drink them and i would
kill that every time because i had the
stretchiest bladder in in louisiana so
that's why you don't pee
i think is that is that a thing that
works your bladder
matt can you fact check that if that's
an actual that feels like people who are
like i can get my dick bigger if i just
pull it out
it's like the same it feels like the
same i've tried that too
i tried all that rolling it out hanging
the weights i just tried
those ab rollers and just [ __ ] yeah
yeah
yeah you can damn i should try i got a
crazy blanket if you're a woman though
you get a you
oh i've had a few of those though yeah
oh
utis utis many utis i didn't know dudes
could get them what are you kidding
oh my god yeah but they're not as common
in men
no no no no no but they come and go i've
never heard of a man like pulling out
right after sex being like i gotta pee
it's an emergency i would do that just
in in uh just to be cautious but you
know dr steve
i know he is i'm not him if you ever
want his number good guy if you need
to need a hand downtown oh yeah always
inspected your garbage
always inspecting if i can oh i caught
your garbage they say you're junk but
your garbage sounds a little more
true it does sound worse your junk is
fine yeah garbage
this is a landfill i guess because junk
can still have value
ah is that what it is oh that's big yes
garbage is just garbage it's ruined
yeah got a picture of a banana peel and
a fish bone yeah but junk could be like
an old record player yeah it's like a
like a little
you know flea sale flea market yeah yeah
garage sale garbage is no good
but yeah uh so i forgot my point
you you you see that touches your your
penis he would he was on speed dial like
i got a uti he's like
cbs go get it i called it in you know
what's funny with all this telehealth
stuff and you're like doing doctor's
appointments on
zoom and [ __ ] like you're really doing
the same [ __ ] as a cam girl
except you're paying them wait what do
you mean well you're whipping your dick
out on a [ __ ] camera
oh yeah except it's a problem it's a
problem
yeah we got to pay people to look at our
dicks yeah they get to get paid
yeah i know like three chicks who failed
in comedy
and now they're killing it not only fans
yeah but that's a it's a
short-lived sure sure it's a short-lived
career on that i guess so but i mean
it's like
it'd be nice to get this it'd be nice
you're doing pretty well on the road no
i'm just saying if if things got weird
it'd be nice wouldn't you be more
satisfied being like do you hear the new
norman bit being like check out mark's
dick
the joke is more satisfying of course i
agree i agree but let's just say
we weren't funny then it'd be nice to be
a
little
there's no fallback what i could be a
garbage man how long could you do
how long could you do that for
realistically though the only fans think
i don't know but i think when a 20k
check comes in a month you're like
it's weird you want to be recognized for
your comedy i don't think you want to be
recognized in the street because you're
like i've seen your dick before oh yeah
that's a good point that's a good point
by the way if you're calling it garbage
a garbage man could be a gay guy
there we go that's the guy's thick guy
loves junk garbage man
yeah he collects just like a garbage man
what was that smell
by the way when i was a kid everybody
would like garbagemen get paid a lot
you know you'll go well really and then
you hear and you're like not nearly
enough
not enough so that that is a thankless
job especially in new york you know how
many
rats they're probably pulling out of
there oh my god you're right that's a
thankless job the
hours are [ __ ] yeah you you smell like
[ __ ]
from it garbage shout out to garbage men
dude that's a tough ass job
and you're up at the crack of jit i mean
how many times have you been drinking
you're like oh the garbage ban around we
better go home
i think they always i don't know i i
heard that a lot growing up too they'd
be like garbagemen make a lot of money
but then
then you hear and you're like can we get
can we get a number on that
what that's not enough in new york oh
that's low
you're keeping this city clean yeah [ __ ]
so let's be real it's not that
sure but that night what is it monday or
tuesday night when all the garbage is on
the corner you're like oh this is a grow
that's like it's like frogger but with
rats you're just having yeah
get through all these the amount of rats
it's
you know when you have you know i have a
west coast girlfriend who when she comes
here
i have to be like it's like new york is
like a shitty roommate yeah that i'm
just like hoping will behave that's
great it's literally like
is that a bit no but it could be this is
gold yeah but it's like it literally is
like
rats like homeless dudes with their
dicks
we got a subway car the other day and
i'm just like ah nice air-conditioned
subway car right she's like
then we turn to the left there i'm
trying you know yeah yeah
there's just a [ __ ] pile of human
[ __ ]
ah and i have to be like oh let's go i
just like grabbed before she could look
i was like oh let's go this way over
here let's sit over here
right it's like you're the divorced dad
with your shitty apartment like
no it's fun it's fun it's a it's a dead
body play with it
hit it with a stick damn that's yeah
you're right that's so true
new york is i love it so much but it's
like
if you don't love it you can't argue
with him
it's insane i mean every time an la
comic trashes new york they all they
always do it it's kind of hack at this
point when they come to new york and
have to live here
to shoot the daily show or whatever and
they're like new york sucks 18
for a smoothie the subway this that
you're like oh yeah it does
that is shitty and then you see their
act and you're like well there's a
reason we live here yeah
yeah exactly but uh but they're right
there's a no they are
there's a point i i get it the quality
of life is better in l.a
oh but yeah but new york comics get up
more they're better at literally
everything else
they're better actors they're better
yeah yeah they're in better shape
they look better they're healthier they
uh they'll probably live longer
yeah they sleep better the industry's
all out there
i get it right i get why you're out
there i mean look larry david moved out
there a lot of new york
born and raised stayed here you got that
right
but also don't you feel like larry's
energy is like
constantly he's like in a constant state
of irritation so that that energy kind
of works anywhere
he'd be annoyed in brooklyn he'd be
annoyed at manhattan
i'll live in la i'll be annoyed yes and
him in la
is a sore thumb and it's it's great for
comedy
oh dude the episode of curve where he
accidentally tripped shaq
and they're like oh there's reports that
he's a knicks man and he did it on
facebook
yes yes that's one of the low-key great
great i hate when i hate when people say
locate that's one of the all-time best
episodes
yeah yeah it's a real sleeper it's a
real sleeper sleep rep or
my girlfriend guys it's a sneaky great
app you're like it's not a sneaker it's
a great app
like like the episodes like that greer
barnes bit when he's sneaking on the
train oh yeah suspicious packages like
the package he acts it out
oh that's funny dumb dude he'd be a good
guest on this once we start doing guests
yeah that's a great i remember that
all-nighter we pulled with him
back at ellie's apartment back like 10
years ago that 88
jesus christ i saw photos it might have
been 11 years ago
yeah we did the strip well chris maybe
we started years ago dude
wow it might be yeah it was you me phil
greer barnes
we we just all night and i remember we
were going through like bottles of
whiskey and i remember
we were hammered and gray was fine yeah
he was telling stories and we're all
like
we're like stumbling and he and he was
just like i was like oh this dude can
drink
oh yeah oh yeah this is this is a pro
with a few amateurs here
yeah you were dating like a real kind of
manhattanite gal
she was real cool man i went to a
gallery the uh like doing the pandemic
we did a show on like a
she we did at one of the roof shows yeah
and i did one there wait it hurt she has
a gallery
she is a gallery in like chinatown it's
a tiny little gallery yeah it's great
that's like a rom-com like a woody allen
movie
but she was she had like she loved
she was great and she was had a great
apartment like upwards
it was a mom's apartment oh okay but
that was my first taste of like
because i was so young then i was
probably like 25 or something we were
kids this is amazing it was all new to
me like a balcony in manhattan what the
[ __ ] she didn't have a balcony
all right one bedroom in manhattan well
it looked huge to me
it was a nice building it was nice very
nice doorman
all that [ __ ] now i'm you know you or
this new york jewish
comedian like the whole thing was very
foreign to me it was fascinating we were
hanging on the upper east we were doing
we were hanging to the strip
yeah yeah i remember she'd have like
parties oh my god
they were fun bar cart and it was very
like beautiful apartment like good
architecture
great bar cart and she put music on i
was like this is high society dude that
would black out
did she put on music on well how long
was your bar it was like [ __ ]
music what was it what's that name it
was like a nat king cole or yeah yeah no
she would play good tunes yeah
we uh there's something about getting
drunk to like jazz
it makes you feel like you're it's like
a higher class of drunk
totally and it's the ups upper east side
it was cold out i mean this is all
nothing i've done we didn't have winter
in new orleans so it was all
very new to me it was fascinating a lot
of you guys if you're watching us on
youtube we're doing a lot of like kind
of summery drinks it's it's hot as
[ __ ] outside ah it's brutal in the
winter i'm kind of pumped to do some
like maybe some
petey scotches maybe we'll get some like
our bag in the mix
right we'll do i love it we'll do it but
maybe we'll fat cat by then maybe we'll
have a ride by then
the good call i i do need it to get cold
i'm not a fan of the summer i hate the
heat
really yeah people are cool why do you
hate the evil i still you know i hate my
dad too
you know it doesn't matter where you're
from joking dad
but uh yeah we had a bit of breakthrough
in this episode man you can't just turn
on it
oh no i'm just worried about the guys
getting old but uh
i hate the heat i can't like my
i don't know my atoms are moving too
fast in my body it's too much you know
like look at all the uh the hot places
they're all at
war you know like cold plate well i
guess russia's [ __ ] psycho too i
take it all back they went out like geez
too what do you mean oh man those world
war two battles i feel like they
lost the most men oh my god could you
imagine
i watched all those documentaries the
dudes putting their feet on the fire
just because they're so cold
like their foot is in the fire yeah we
[ __ ] about
everything these guys were out there for
like you know six years or whatever it's
great stories when they would get like
they would have to go cannibal when
they'd be so starved
they would like talk about how like the
butt has the meatiest uh
yeah so they literally ate bud yeah
there you go
yeah but i mean that's like good point
that's [ __ ]
brutal brutal brutal and they would eat
those mres and like a cigarette was a
treat like uh i got a cigarette you know
just what a nightmare like the rats the
trenches
the cold we complain about ac i know
i know got to change the filter here we
go
you should see the complaints i mean
like you think about it sometimes i'm
like oh wi-fi goes out for one [ __ ]
minute
these people were like ugh and they
don't live in debris
yeah they don't talk about the war
either which als i think kind of hurts
their cause because i feel like
you know if someone's like i was
triggered and i i don't i didn't i felt
threatened you're like okay
let's hear it but these guys didn't talk
about it so they don't get the love
either
yeah that's a that's a good point it's
like it's all about like
you just kind of let those people talk
the least yes it's literally like
grandkids like uh grandpa do you want to
do my podcast
and they're like oh i don't it's kind of
painful for me to talk because well on
my podcast we try to be real
right right exactly you know i would
talk about the war if i was in the war
but that's cool
but they they can't articulate i get why
they don't talk about it because imagine
trying to be like okay
here we did this or like oh yeah i've
been i've been skiing i get the cold
like now you don't get it
they've shell shocked yeah so uh i
wouldn't talk about it either
another week you haven't watched rick
and morty we're gonna get you on it
this is the week this is a week yeah
going to martha's vineyard next week
what any a show or just a big hay just a
vacay the lady
has a has a pad out there so we're gonna
go i've never been
i've never been either i'm not a beach
guy but i'm going to get a bite
we're very similar in a lot of ways i'm
not i hate the beach i don't get it
i don't hate her but i just like i'd
rather sit in a bar with with a
with music and a and a bartender
sweeping up and you know i think we're
trash i mean like maybe
i think like it's classy to like the
beach and i think like i'm always kind
of like i like like a pool side
like yeah a hotel like a pool i'll do
poolside i mean look there's some trash
on the beach don't
get me wrong so the beach is cheap
so i think there is a lot of like poor
people go to the beach and and
[ __ ] bring speakers and live it up
true so
the beach can go away but then you got
the hamptons the beach is a lot of range
not big on sand is like a real
deal breaker for me i know i understand
i don't get it you just it ruins
you you ruins the bathing suit you got
to shake everything out
yeah sticks to you yeah you got to deal
with jellyfish you got to deal with yes
like it's constant sun then you're
sweaty and you're kind of burny
sanders and it's just it's too much you
are pink by the end
but no it's it's dude it's i'll go i'm
not i'm not
so hard against it if someone's like
really passionate about him like all
right i'll go i mean i was in ac
a few weeks ago and devito was there
with his girlfriend
and she was like very much like we need
to go to the beach and luckily i was in
too much pain to even get out of the
hotel
but they got like a banner or something
oh good good but that sounds it sounded
fun if i was up to it i would have gone
yeah but it it's
i guess it could be i mean you get a
book and you just sit in the towel it's
kind of nice
sure sure but i feel like you could do
that on a terrace or in a backyard
but how did you get in the water not at
the beach
oh well there you go how about you i do
just because i'm like it's there i got
to do it but
i don't unless i'm surfing or boogie
boarding can you surf i've never done it
i would love to try it
yeah it looks fun yeah but i never had a
good wave
i mean i think i think you gotta like
learn it i think yeah
i think you're right but yeah it just
always looks like
i don't know yeah something i need
something to do i just end up getting
shit-faced because i'm like
i need a drink or i'm just sitting here
i don't know what to do
yeah you know what i think looks like
cool vacation-wise is like a poolside
bar
we just like swim up and they hand you
like a
a vodka that looks fun that looks great
yeah there's a cool charming bartender
we worked our vacations around the bar
of course of course yeah i'm on vacation
to turn it off so i need the alcohol to
like shut me down
or else i'm like i should be tweeting i
should be uh instagramming i should be
potting you know
yeah that's so true yeah like we we
there's something about
it's so hard for us to show we we work
for so long to get to a point where
like my add is so bad stand up it took
so long to get to a
comfortable and like safe place with
stand up
that it's hard you're like what am i
just supposed to shut down yes yes
you you lie it's almost like a kid like
we work so hard to get you into college
and we finally are you're a good kid and
you're smart and you're
uh accomplished i can't just leave you
yeah you know
we we built this thing up to something
it's like a like a restaurant like five
of the restaurants in the black
and white am i just gonna go go leave it
no i gotta stick with it
yeah it's tough right it's a business it
is tough
uh yeah yeah like that's why booze will
never be illegal
look booze kills people all the time uh
drunk driving you know
domestic abuse it's horrible for people
but
it takes the edge off yeah we need it we
need a drink every now and then i know
we do
that maybe that's a bit ah well think
about that like
murder violence drunk driving you're
like
but it makes you comfortable in the
first days yeah yeah it keeps the world
lubricated
in a way you know like a lube is always
good lube is good
social lube engine lube yeah all that
actual lube
yeah sexual lube have you ever done lube
have i done it
have you used lube with your ladies yeah
of course oh my god you have to
it's a game changer what am i a
superhero
i don't i try not to use it because it's
too good it's almost like doing blow or
something
really where i'm like i don't want to
need this all the time sure sure
you want to earn it it doesn't feel
better if you if you weren't and my gal
is a real
gusher i mean she's squirting out all
kinds of stuff so
mine's more of a fruit roll-up i thought
we're just doing candy i don't know
but uh no i i know you mean though but
lube
you gotta get the naturals you don't
want to get that ky
jelly what's the natural it's just any
kind that's like not chemical
oh okay you don't want to like because
you know i just think the natural is
like safer
yeah no i'm with you on that but they
have all these weird ones where it's
like warming massage yeah you're like i
don't trust any of this [ __ ] i don't
like that at all no
i'm with you but lube it is an itchy
dick
[Laughter]
itchy dick that's a great turn that
sounds like a carlin thing end up with
an itchy dick
but the andy dick's brother by the way
but
it's uh luke's great on news radio yeah
lube is great but it it does take a
second where you're like hold on let me
get the lube
and that kind of can kill you out of it
a little bit takes you out of it we have
too many things
yeah yeah you can have too many
accessories completely yeah that's why
the condom that's why it's great being a
relationship because that condom was a
whole thing
it's almost like when you're having a
cocktail and you take out the shaker and
the stir
and sometimes you're like i just need
the drink yes exactly you can deal with
this stuff
later but that's kind of what it all is
you're kind of like all right i'm out of
i'm i
i have the need to do it right now right
right maybe they'll be a lube ologist
you know there's a mixologist who's like
say he like makes a thing out of it
there'll be a new dick you're like
olives
[Laughter]
oh yeah oh i got to do a wreck or a pee
with the record i got i got some pigs oh
baby all right by the way look at this
hold on my moon is on
oh it worked calls and notifications
will be silenced
isn't that nice this is my first time
yeah i love it man you busted your
cherry but i'll tell you man it's it's
nice i think it's
i think matt would you ever do that you
do the do not disturb you do
oh [ __ ] occasionally you miss important
calls here and there but like
they either call back or like it's worth
it for the overall
just kind of piece yeah because
otherwise your phone is vibrating with
like push notifications
it's like cnn huffington post you know
my mom
you know it's just right right the last
one was a joke
but uh oh i believed you
but it's all news i know but i wouldn't
ignore her you know but it does add up
to a point like i just like to bang this
all out
my thing is like if it's really
important call me right and i'll call
you back
right yeah i can't do the texting all
day and you get stuck in doing the
texting all day
and you just can't do other [ __ ] yeah no
i'm here with you
last thing i'll say about booze you know
i i
listen to some podcasts where i
historians on my booze it kept people
alive for years
yeah because you couldn't drink water
because it was too dirty
so they drank alcohol because it would
kill the germs
so kids would drink cider and [ __ ] at
breakfast so in that kind of fun that
booze
kept people hydrated and they didn't
but booze dehydrated i know but you
would the beer was like considered like
a cat it was almost like a protein shake
like we gotta have a beer break and
and keep farming wow yeah what do you
think is refreshing even though it
dehydrates you like
you work really hard all day oh you pop
a cold one
yeah there's something like you i get
happy hour like i get needing a drink
definitely you know
you ever seen uh of course you've seen
shawshank that scene where they they tar
the roof and they have that bucket of
beers with the italian opera you're like
oh man that beer looks good
shawn shanks tough not to watch i know
whenever if
that's like it's like got that good
fella's effect where like if it's on tv
it's
and it's always on tv like that's one
where i'm on the road i'm like all right
i'll [ __ ]
every time i'm in the gym or something
and it's on him i got right every i mean
morgan freeman and
tim robbins character tim robbins is is
kind of underrated
i agree he's always good uh always how
tall is he he's i bet he's six
through six four yeah i'm going i think
he's a tall
couple old durham you look pretty big
yeah if you play an athlete you got to
be pretty big
yeah six five yeah whoa that's a big guy
yeah and he uh banging sarandon well he
used to they're not together no they're
not
no but he had you know what else he did
he did what was the one
um mystic river's great you know what's
the robert altman movie where he's
killer you know what i'm talking about
uh-oh uh
where's the agent agent
robert allman movie oh not the the
country music one
no no i'm thinking of prairie home
companion that's woody and what's that
what's the
robert allman one uh look at robert
altman and and tim robinson the player
the player that's a [ __ ] great yeah
wow i haven't heard about that movie in
a while
brought to you by sheath underwear this
keeps your ball off your leg
two pouches one for your dick one for
your balls
keeps the ammo separate from the gun
this is great underwear i actually use
this
this is my girlfriend's favorite
underwear this gets me laid
this underwear supportive sexy looking i
really do
this is my favorite underwear i'm not
just saying this i'm not just saying
this because they're paying us money i
really
think there's quality underwear uh the
idea from sheath came from the founder
us army soldier robert padden during his
second tour in iraq
are you guys going to support the troops
award support this awesome veteran-owned
company who's founder he's a big comedy
fan he's messaged me he's a great dude i
always message you too go to sheath
underwear dot com and order with promo
code drunk
to get 20 off your first order and
sheath
underwears 100 money back guarantee that
sheath underwear dot com
promo code drunk get sheath underwear
and let them support
your balls altman you don't hear about
it
enough one of the greatest yeah
yeah nashville might be ah
might be might be i mean that's in the
conversation for best musical ever i
think
really i think it's [ __ ] brilliant
a lot of musicals about places chicago
nashville oklahoma
chicago is fun great great time never
saw oklahoma
oh it's it's cute but it's campy old
[ __ ]
nashville is dark i love it man yeah
yeah
you're going there soon oh yeah i'll be
there dude i love uh
[ __ ] lily tomlin got an oscar not for
that movie keith carradine won the oscar
for best song that's a great song
yes that's a great song that is a great
song man
good good pull on nashville yeah all
right here's my dumb
wreck you did your wreck yeah sideways
oh great it's right i had to rent it but
man
it's just quotable it's worth it
i was laughing you get touched by it
i think everyone got nominated about
giamatti too it was like a loaded view
yeah
well everyone's grading it but like damn
you like it's really his movie
wow but uh yeah just like a great great
movie that's my favorite kind of movie
there's
just that like people interacting kind
of movie like social
yeah what i don't know what you call it
i know they call it a drama or a drama
it's a dramatic probably but there
aren't enough that get that balance
right
where it's funny without being kind of
like preachy or yeah
like heavy-handed like all the scenes
that felt kind of like a little heavy i
felt like they earned it
yeah it completely wow it's such a hard
like it's hard to think of other movies
that do it that well
yeah and it's silly at points too like
with the the
the closer is so great with the fat guy
running down the street naked and all
that
i was dying i knew it was coming i was
like i was like
just [ __ ] pumped to watch it
just the idea that he runs back naked
yeah
and yeah and and paul giamatti is like
like every step is like are you out of
your [ __ ] mom but the same time you
know you're thinking i chose this
[ __ ] as my friend
yeah i'm his best man it's like there is
that thing where like for better or
worse
i'm stuck with my [ __ ] friends and
it's kind of thing there's something
kind of beautiful about that
they get you in [ __ ] you can't stand
them but you love them
and you still kind of got to do this yes
i mean it's kind of just perfect so i
don't know
but you tell me your wreck no that's you
you nailed the movie there
uh he's like i had my i got my [ __ ] in
her ass talk about the asian lady oh man
it's got silliness and it's not
pretentious all right and there's like
tender moments but it's also just so
[ __ ]
silly like oh yeah like the fact that
he's just obsessed with a wine is such a
funny dream right like it's just like
because that movie could be about
anything it's not really about wine of
course
you know but but the wine is the perfect
way to get into it yep yep yep
i think a lot of all great movies and
comedy i think is like that like you're
talking about the subway
and there's no subway in in cleveland or
whatever but
they know what you're feeling and i
think that's the
that's the you know you're like feeling
a discomfort yeah
yeah like do you have to change your act
when you go like no no people will get
it
they get what i'm saying they've been in
new york they've seen movies about new
york yeah
or they just get it yeah i've been on a
bus
i've never had to change a new york joke
never same here
same here like you know you go to
australia or whatever and you're like do
they have uber here like
they'll get it they know what you're
talking about
all right now this is cheesy i'm a big
self-help self-improvement douche and uh
one trick i learned i want to read more
i see all these books i have stacks of
books i order books and i never read
them
so you know you go i'm going gonna read
that book that book looks amazing and i
just let it sit there
here's the trick read a page a day you
said this in another episode
i think you did all right i got a new i
gotta know it's a good one though
it's a good one because then it it's all
gary goldman once had the best writing
advice and i hope i'm not just
completely repeating no no
i haven't heard this but he goes he goes
it's hard to write i'm like yeah it's
hard the getting up and sitting down
and putting the pen to paper is hard
once you're writing it's not that bad
but the
doing it is the hard part same with the
gym getting to the gym
woody allen said the uh most of life is
showing up
90 of life is showing up which is true
once you get to the gym you're not going
to just leave you're going to do it
so if you listen to a set
it'll help you start writing which is a
great way to
you know transition painful it's painful
but it's
i hate listening to myself but like
listening to you
yeah but no i don't hate it but it
really
uh yeah it's necessary
you gotta do it so that's why the page a
day is good because you're like page a
day and that's even
kind of challenging but do it on the
[ __ ]
anymore yeah and uh yeah it's it's great
advice man
but if i've done that i'll get another
one
get on and this is gonna sound
weird but get on robin hood everybody
out there what is it
that's the stock app oh [ __ ] i mean i
know nothing about stocks i'm ignorant
i'm a douche i'm clueless but did you
bail on amc do you get out
i should have i took a real hit it was a
pump and dump
ah somebody tweeted at me go on aiming
i made like three grand like i took it
all out but uh
boy i took a real hit but yeah just get
on it
throw a couple bucks in have fun with it
play with it invest some [ __ ]
turn it off look at it again in a month
i think just try it
it's a good way for idiots like me
who don't know anything about math or
numbers or money to just
dabble in it it's a good way for us to
get our feet our toe in the pool
interesting yeah i never do it yeah
that's new for me but
it's a this app exists and you might as
well take advantage
smart all right that's a little tip
give me a peeve if you got stock tips
please send them my way
now i hope i haven't done this pee
before this is a that's kind of a
heartfelt app
with that i love it man i think it's
good i think it's good stuff matt
you got to have these every now and then
yeah yeah uh we opened with
beating up children so i feel like that
gave us some
some leeway but uh peeve
the guy you ever had this the guy who
texts you with a favor
which is fine the guy you never see or
talk to or hear about or whatever
he's like hey can you do me a favor
you're like all right what do you got
okay can you do me a favor tell me who
this is first
yeah that's i didn't save your number
because the last two times you text me
was a favor
as well so true i gotta start saving now
you save it as like jeff
favor because that's all that's all you
know him for it's like bonnie big tits
you know or red robin or whatever so uh
jeff hits me up i haven't talked to this
guy
pre-pandemic since then hey can you do
me a favor
what's up man what's up and then after
that i go yeah i got you goes
how are you oh now are you gonna pull
out how are you after the favor is done
first of all i hate the how are you
because you're like
it's clearly like oh i should ask him
about his day because
he's doing me a favor so it's so
contrived but
but uh i hate the how are you because
now i gotta go things
are good but now i gotta play your dumb
game which i hate doing
just because you feel bad right you
don't care how i am
so that's my peeve yeah it's tough i'm
sure
i'm trying to have you know empathy for
that situation i also think i've done
that before
where i've been like well if you're like
how are you you're you're a friend we
talk all the time it's like oh
you know you're like if it's someone you
don't know that's what it is i don't
know the guy and it's
clearly like oh i should be polite now
it's it's so
obvious i definitely there are people i
don't see enough and sometimes the text
like miss you how are you but yeah i
think with the favors
with the favorites yeah that's the thing
that's the thing it's it this guy's a
scum yeah it's like ratso rizzo and
midnight cowboy it feels
completely forced and i don't hate on
rats so that guy
he had a tough life though that guy i
mean i like the guy it's a great
character but i don't hang out with him
i'm walking here great great movie great
scene that was improvised that line
great uh
great is he a new yorker hoffman huffman
he must
he must be man he [ __ ]
ran the 60s oh my god marathon man the
graduate and bancroft from uh the bronx
arthur avenue gotta love this she ended
up with mel brooks too
i know that's one for the comedy guys
smoke show sexy as hell by the way she
was like 38
in the graduate i know that's what
that's what a milf was back yeah
even then i think even then they were
like i think she's too old
isn't that funny that's hilarious
yeah man [ __ ] huh
oh you hate to hear that yeah i mean
ellie's got good juice
that's true that's true i'm good l.a
jews there are some good la jews
he really he's really just like one of
the best ever
yeah such a great actor seems like a
cool guy funny
fun guy in a lot of comedies you know
he's in uh
meet the [ __ ] tootsie tootsie
yeah hook hook
[ __ ] that's like i remember that as a
kid yeah he was captain hook
what okay let me give you a pee hit me
with a peeve i got a couple
one is okay this is hitting me hard i
think this is this is very drinkable
yeah it's very drinkable i get it now so
it [ __ ] goes down pretty well yeah
once you get past that initial
bitterness
got a kick kind of like us a little bit
interest up top
we're [ __ ] why this is 12 oh i know
that's high
i knew we were going into oh my god i
got four shows
well you're gonna have a buzz buzzform
what are you gonna do all right
give me the babe i've got two shows i'll
be all right
um my peeve okay so i'm on my flight
and the guy in front of me he's like
it's like one of the things we're like
are you
out of your mind he's looking at like
literally i'm in the first row waiting
for him to move
and he goes 14 14.
and i'm like oh i'm with you well you
know it's not here
yeah you know it's not the first row
i've seen
and it goes 14 i'm just like it's that
way what do you think
you think it's towards the cockpit it
ain't up and ain't down it's straight on
we're two fourteen three what comes
after the number one
yes yes go this way i've seen the guy's
going
hold on he literally looked at me like
for help and i'm like do you need help
with
14 go man who is who are these guys
parents what is wrong with this guy
i'll tell you what even if i don't know
the language i know i know enough
that that ain't one right right i don't
care if you're on the metric system
i don't care if you're from the middle
east it's
[ __ ] laid out for you this could be
simpler yeah i was just like come on so
that was one i didn't i'm with you
i have another one for you all right
this [ __ ] happens all the time where
you're on the subway
and the dude like they just don't have
headphones and they're just listening to
the music like this
through the speaker and you're just like
hey guess what i lost my headphones on
the road last weekend you know what i
did
i sucked it up and looked at the [ __ ]
window here here
i sucked up and didn't listen to music
for a minute we're living in a society
it's so [ __ ] rude and guess what it's
never like something by the way i know
there's never a podcast it's never like
they're never holding their phone up
like this and they're like this is fresh
air with terry gross
hold on i gotta put on tipping point
with malcolm gladwell
it's never that you're right it's always
just like some techno [ __ ]
you're like thank you yeah my life is
[ __ ] shittier because i've met you
i know i know suck it up be considerate
you're making strangers lives worse
yeah that's it in a nutshell you know
who you are
that's the same you are making people
you've never met you
you're annoying them yeah and they're
taking that energy with them to the next
place
yes i saw a new york post article today
man on subway slashed for telling a guy
to turn his radio down
the guy in the radio just how did it cut
it out what's that i better cut it out
i know right he got this guy but it's
it's scary because you know if you're
doing the the music
out loud like you're off already yeah
you're not you're not aware you're not
thinking about other people yeah so like
but turning it down like this but it's
you know what i think they're close
enough to us
i'm like well they own a phone yeah but
i mean
every homeless guy he's got a phone yeah
that's a weird one isn't it yeah that is
odd like you have a tick tock
what plan do you have yeah amy when you
can
right is there a hobo plan there must be
because they're doing well
it's definitely t-mobile it's gotta be
always on the move yeah or cricket
whatever the [ __ ] that is
i've seen cricket around but yeah that's
true
yeah what is that with the no headphones
get some [ __ ] headphones suck it up
go to that weird
electronic store in the airport pay the
overpriced amount because you lost them
yeah i knew i wanted an airpod so i
[ __ ] i waited it out
yeah wait till i get back i'm not going
to buy some you know
[ __ ] pear you lost those you lost
your pods
yeah they were a gift too i felt bad i
lost mine too
it sucks to lose the airpods and they
also i mean
they really [ __ ] apple
give a pair out every once in a while
they have to cost 275 bucks oh
exactly criminals and they the with all
so many people criminals by the way
i've noticed that's like my new thing
i'm just like [ __ ] criminal i like
that
they're designed in a way too they they
slip away you know they'll slip into a
couch or they'll go down a great you
know they
just that eggshell kind of smooth
no corners they just slip out of your
life
they're so evil i picture them just like
testing them in the lab
and they're like make sure they fall
through this way right here exactly
they fell through perfect exactly just
sneaky enough
exactly and somebody told me that look
you can look this up
iphones are designed to start not
working after three years i'm sure
like a relationship but uh it's it's
like mine stopped working after six
months
that must been a samsung but yeah it's
true it's like come on what are you
doing to us and i get it they're trying
to make a buck but like
we're trying to be happy here and live
our lives
it's a great point i mean they do break
but then i'm also like i just look at it
like taxes at this point i'm like i'm
going to spend
a certain amount of money on a phone
because i use it so damn much
yeah where we're hooked they got us by
the balls man it's our calendar our e
our mail
our weather our recording we're so
dependent on it podcast you got a book
on there
i don't know how the amish do it i feel
like i go without a phone for like a day
and i'm just like oh i go nuts oh man
dude
i went without headphones and i was like
i'm [ __ ] strong yeah
yes yes i give myself a feeling please i
was like i'm pretty i'm a strong man
i know but i bet if you did like if you
did 10 days without it
you you would make it well you used to
have a bit about like
you know you didn't have a bit where
you're like i have to listen to my
thoughts
it was like you ever forget your
headphones and you realize thoughts are
not good
and then it's it's this long bit about
how
you know it's good to drown that [ __ ]
out every now and then and uh make it
it's like
it's like a mental cleansing yeah people
like juice
yes it's like that for your brain
exactly
i try to listen like i only listen to
like
music with lyrics like i try to cut that
back a little bit because if
i do it too much i'm not gonna be
thinking of jokes or something if i
listen to jazz or like
classical i can kind of like listen to
that and still kind of like be like a
bit idea a bit idea
but if i'm just listening to like you
know [ __ ] staying alive by the bg's
i'm just you know i'm like i'm not
thinking abyss i'm like
i'm doing a little [ __ ] dance that's
true yeah but i do need music like that
to get me amped like
it's either that or like three six pm
coffees on the road
oh yeah i'd like to keep it to one at
that time yeah
somebody gave me a hot tip they said
listen to video game music
because it's designed to like ramp your
brain up
but i tried and it was too it was too
rampy i don't i don't buy that because i
think like video games like
i never feel connected after listening
uh
like i play video games i'm never like
man my brain feels good
no same same we're lucky we're not
i know guys we'll spend nine hours on
call of duty i can't
i mean like i'd love to i mean during
the pandemic
uh taylor and i would do like we i
bought an xbox for la
yeah and we and we started playing halo
co-op mode
it was so [ __ ] fun that is great dude
it also like you end up enjoying each
other a lot yes you're like
literally like get down i got you here
you know you're like talk you're like
have each other's back and you're
shooting people yeah one of them's lean
when he's leading the way the other just
like shooting it's [ __ ] fun that
sounds nice i got i get why people
lose not but we would like play for like
four hours and be like oh
my our [ __ ] lives like we got to do
something productive
yeah we even burned through i used to
play candy crush for like two days and
my girlfriend's like you gotta like go
to
get a shower it's addictive it's
addictive games are the only one i'll do
now
at all i'll i have a ps4 at home and
i'll do like uh
i'll do like nba 2k just when i'm like
i'll like listen to a podcast or
something and just play just to like
but i'm not even really playing i'm
doing like front office mode i'm making
trades and [ __ ] that's what happens when
you get older you like
you only want to play the game you just
want to like restore the franchise yeah
i just like want the knicks to be good
again and like a make-believe game right
right yeah yeah it'd be nice if you do
that with your own life like all right
i'm at a job interview
i can kill sims right is that the sims
isn't that kind of the sims like you
kind of make a guy and he has got a life
oh really i thought it was just sim city
that's where i
stopped what's him saying we're [ __ ]
old and we're getting old
sim city i cuz like the fact that i even
get that reference you're like the
football stadium
yeah you build a football stadium yeah
we need roads we're building out
suburbs yeah yeah that was fun that's
the [ __ ] best
oh yeah but video games have come a long
way and people are gonna start [ __ ]
that's gonna be a thing in video games
oh yeah i guarantee it really with with
virtual reality the way it's going
it's gonna be crazy maybe that'll be
like what tinder is in the future
i think so like virtual [ __ ] before you
meet
probably we're just gonna keep filtering
it's crazy that you just oh there's no
substitute for real
like no no but like i think to meet
people it's gonna keep
we're already doing like no no yes no no
yes
just off appearance basically wow yeah
and then it's gonna be like
let's see how we'd be sexually
compatible exactly yeah you're gonna
[ __ ] like virtually before you even meet
yeah i don't want to waste my time with
someone i'm not sexually compatible with
and then like here's what's gonna happen
next when you're like if you're in a
long distance thing
they'll make like molds of your dick and
vagina so you can like
[ __ ] on facetime that'll be like the
next thing you're right
don't you think holy [ __ ] that'll
probably be the next move
that's one way where guys are lucky it's
like our dicks are concealed to the last
minute
you know like women's kind of tits are
out you can see unless you're a [ __ ]
subway pervert
that's what they that's what they open
with i don't think they're uh really
hitting the dating scene i prefer them
to the [ __ ] people without the
headphones
i agree at least they're keeping
themselves at least they're [ __ ] like
i'm like that's deeply mentally ill yeah
you're just [ __ ] rude
yeah right i'll take like rude i'm like
[ __ ] you you're closer to us
you should know better yes whipping the
dick and i'm like you're far gone
you're you're mentally i mean that's a
good point that's a good point
uh the guy at my old gym used to blare
the music and you're like what are you
doing like
who wants to hit and i would have
headphones in so i would jack him up
and i he would always give me like a
weird look other noise that's external
is [ __ ] annoying yeah there's just
construction going on in my building all
day and i'm like
enough yeah i'm trying to [ __ ] like i'm
that's the thing about the pandemic is
like once it hit
a lot of people started working from
home more so people that are like always
doing [ __ ] in their homes i'm like
wrap it up i know like a lot of us this
is our office now
yes and there's always our office true
but our schedules are a little different
too like some people like all right
people go to work at nine and we'll
start doing construction at nine they're
like
ah i'm sleeping at nine oh it's no one
respects a night schedule
no people like us bartenders
anyone who just works at night waitstaff
who works late nights no one respects us
because we're not normal society they
look at us as like
almost like failures or something yes
where they're like well you're not
successful you work at night and we're
like no we're doing all right but yeah
but they look at us as like well you're
others at least
you're others well because to most
people it's like
dinner day like how many girlfriends
have you had like just skip the show
let's get dinner
let's go watch a concert you're like
that's when i work not a lot cause it
didn't last long
yeah exactly that never left when they
dinner is a sign of stability
to a partner oh yeah you know like he's
loved dinner we'll breakfast and lunch
the [ __ ] out of here but
guess what like dinner it's like now
we're at a point we can kind of like
navigate the shows around
our other [ __ ] yeah there was many
years we were like
it's this or nothing this is it this is
my job and i got to get better at it and
i got to take this gig this is at a club
this is at a place i want to keep
working and they're like ah
you're like you knew i was a comic you
you're banging me because i'm a comic
i know you don't want me to do comedy
they like you but they want you they
they're just
trying to change you to be something
slightly different
they see something they like about yeah
and they're like let me just try to
shift it
right over here and you're like i ain't
moving you got that right this is it
this is it this is who i am uh
i mean [ __ ] there is funny during
breakups for me i'm like i'll change
anything i'll do whatever and then i'm
like oh no i won't
why'd i say that yeah yeah totally i
mean look guys do it too they go meet
some stripper and they're like i think
you should stop stripping
it's like well that's how you met me you
psycho um this is who i am i'm a
stripper all the way
then that stripper is like i should
start comedy stormy daniels you ruined
it for everybody
oh jordan daniels man what a [ __ ]
what a run i know i
it's fun because i jerked off to her
because he already it's fun
well i watched her porn because you see
her on the news like you know her and
then you get to watch the porn after
that and you're like
i mean the fact that she was threatened
was pretty [ __ ] up i thought wait what
a threat
yeah one of trump's goons i think it was
wasn't michael cohen man who threatened
yeah he threatened her like
he was a goon he's like a [ __ ] goomba
lawyer really
a jumba lawyer
well he was a [ __ ] it's hilarious i
heard him on bill maher and he was like
really trying to be like
you know this [ __ ] should be in
prison you're like didn't you just get
out of prison
like you're you're not the most credible
i'm like i'm not trump's trash but like
you're not the most credible
person ever right i think he's on like
this redemption tour
oh wow i'm sure he's i think he's got a
book deal or something
i'm sure anyone who's close to trump
they're like we'll pay you big money
yeah yeah so wait
he threatened to hit her or sewer or i
think it was just like
something along the lines of like
be quiet or else i think i'm like oh
yeah
well she she's got guts because she does
have guts i'll give it to her i mean
like yeah she went out and
spread the news i'd be a much bigger fan
if she wasn't doing like one-nighters at
comedy clubs
but i guess i guess that's a transitory
uh existence as they
sure had to do what she does and uh i've
been to many comedy clubs they're like
oh it's a light night story daniel sold
it out last night
come on i'll blow you
whatever you want but yeah i wonder like
it's pretty hot i mean she's a hot lady
yeah yeah i mean that's her thing
that's her thing yeah but it's fun
seeing a woman on the news and be like
oh i can just
type my fingers and see her getting
railed by some uh italian guy that's
your other thing
that's the other thing yeah and it's fun
it's fun to get to know someone
you know how sometimes you meet an actor
when they're old and you're like oh yeah
and then you see them young you're like
wow
look at that it was fun seeing a
personal news and
going back and seeing the [ __ ] yeah yeah
it is interesting yeah should we do bits
let's do a bit are we have we gone long
are we good i think we're a little long
all right well we'll keep it tight here
what do you got there
hairy legs you i do have hairy legs same
same
what uh i'm hairy legged and nowhere
else
really yeah it's weird i got the happy
trail yeah you got nothing on your chest
i'm gonna hear you guys
harry is good my girlfriend's always
like i wish you were hairier really
so harry's in yeah i've never had like i
had one girlfriend when i was in like
college
and she uh she she was like can i shave
your chest and i was like
yeah i guess yeah i've never had every
other woman i've ever dated like she was
like
into some [ __ ] lesbian she was
anti-she was anti-fucking jew i think
i think she was like anti-semitic i
think she was i think she was against
that she was like can i shave your chest
and she took a razor and shaved it and i
was like wow
i was like i definitely look in better
shape without the hair like the hair
just makes you look a little more washed
up
you think i thought the hair would like
hide some some bed
i'm sure it does a little bit of that
too but i don't know interesting
uh yeah she shaved and i remember being
like who am i i just shaved my chest i
let a woman shave my chest
yeah my dad would he was the hairiest
guy ever and he shaved i was like
get out of the house yeah it's almost
like a [ __ ]
you get a scarlet letter yeah completely
completely it's almost like what are you
doing i
uh yeah i regret it yeah i was young i
didn't i know and i was like oh i guess
i should do that
yeah no this is better no i'm a hairy
i'm a hairy guy
right in ladies let us know what you
think yeah let me know what you think
uh what do i have um i don't have a lot
honestly because all my [ __ ]
they're either hitting or they're just
[ __ ] and that's worth bringing here so i
either have bits that are working or
just garbage
um let's see what i get i will say i did
a we were riffing last night on the show
and i did a
i did a joke in here and it killed with
you and salaccus and i did on stage in a
hit so i think i might have a bit there
what is it
it was just about like you're allowed to
be shallow if the woman
is marginalized like i was like i gotta
i got a
big titty poster here and everybody's
like jeez you creep and i'm like well
they're trans and everybody's like oh
great love the poster
and it's killing that's good yeah it
calls out it calls out a [ __ ] factor
right right this isn't the bit but
there's something about this i think you
said last week with uh
with my friend wilson vince who would do
the thing oh you know he's black and he
would come by me give me all your
[ __ ] money like ah
that's a great i love that angle and
then you go you're racist and i'd be
like
[Music]
i mean you should give me all your
[ __ ] i don't even see you you're just
like giving me [ __ ] money
so i'm trying to think i need like an
angle this might be something like i
think like
i think the animals may be like the
message trumps the messenger
yeah i'm gonna kill you know what i mean
that's a good way to do something like
just to put the theory to test i send
him a message from a fake email account
moshe greenberg
i have your son if he comes back you
[ __ ] jew
you're right right right yeah yeah you
know what i mean there's something there
that's not the bit though let's see it's
the message more than the messenger i
couldn't even see the messenger
that's the thing all right let me try
this i wouldn't say he's racist in that
in that argument because he's saying
like oh you assume you're making this
about race
yeah so here's one i have a thing about
um
it's not really a bit but there's
something i was thinking about because i
had the doctor's appointment today
i really doctors are just i'm almost
glad
that the pandemic like knock on wood
that delta
dies down a little bit people get
vaccinated and [ __ ] but like
you know some of these [ __ ]
doctors it's like i'm sick of calling
them heroes they're so dismissive
we need a course at medical school for
bedside manner
yeah can we get one course where you
learn how to talk to a human being
right don't act like you all think
you're dr [ __ ] house
every doctor comes in so what was the
joke i wrote down it was like
so this guy he he uh
like so i have the spinal problem and
he's like he's skimming my chart and he
just starts humming
while he's doing it i'm like could you
maybe not approach my life with the same
energy as uh a prison chain yard gang
you know yeah like is this my [ __ ]
like is this like a long-term problem or
cool hand luke
right right yeah it's true because they
they look at us as we're the product
like we're just
on a conveyor belt you're the 13th guy
he's seen a lot of [ __ ] money the
problem is we're all desperate
it's literally if you walked into a
restaurant you were like i'm starving
yeah i waited [ __ ] weeks to get this
reservation
that's good even shitty doctors right
like can you imagine like
like can you imagine going to a shitty
restaurant you're like thank god we got
here
yeah thank god i made it to wendy's i
i've waited months for this
yeah yeah right right and it's all like
you wanna you want a spicy chicken
sandwich that'll be 445 dollars
yeah but i used to bring a car into a
shop and you're like
i don't have a lot of money please don't
be anything bad please don't even that
was just a car and that was just about
money this is about cancer
or whatever the hell scary thing i might
need surgery i might need this
so this is my life and you can't just be
humming
i think that's a that's a good angle
tell me about the humming yeah yeah like
that type of uh nonchalant
casualness could you maybe uh
can you maybe pretend to give a [ __ ]
yeah yeah can you maybe
i mean i think that's the thing where
it's like that's could be an angle put
every doctor in an improv
class too like just so they have they
know how to like
okay this guy's going to want this i
know where to go i'm in an acting class
just like yeah
just like where you're like pretend i
understand this is
stressful for you give them some [ __ ]
basic lines like yeah
my girlfriend and i like we fight and
there's like basic
lines we have to patch things up like if
she's upset
i don't say i go yes
i understand you're upset that must be
tough right you have lines you say
because you see they're upset and yes
could you maybe approach
like you're in a this is a [ __ ] high
stress job
exactly you know maybe that's the angle
i only want doctors with girlfriends
or a married doctor that's not bad yeah
that's not bad because you know like
your girlfriend goes do i look fat in
this you just know what to say you know
the moves
and he should know the moves with the
patient funny my dad's always like see
the jew
see the jewish doctor
he thinks there'll be a better
connection yeah that's hilarious
that's so funny see the jew how do you
say that in the lobby
you guys have a jew yeah because it
could go either way
it sounds like you hate jews too who
which one is jewish
i don't want that guy your appointment
with dr wang do you have a doctor cohn
yeah or dr cone to be more my speed here
at least the jew though will take
everything seriously he'll be like
jesus christ oh my god are you gonna be
okay you're like yeah yeah it's a pimple
they're not like that
really yeah oh my god i'm from a family
of jewish doctors they're [ __ ] like
all right here we go no it's just
doctors are just cynical the way we're
cynical with comedy
they're cynical they deal with idiots
all day
right right they deal with people in
hypochondriacs and they're just tired
and overworked and jaded they're
arrogant it's a [ __ ] annoying
combination
yeah so there's this thing where they're
like
what do you got you're like a sharp pain
in my neck and they're like
huh yeah did they do this for you're
like
i'm in pain as we're speaking can you
not talk down to me
yeah yeah i don't know we'll i'll figure
it out it's not a mechanic
i have feelings i'm not a honda please
relate to me talk to me i'm scared how
about you get you get this one with the
doctor
you're like uh he looks at the chart and
goes ooh
what do you mean so you don't want too
much reaction either
but you want some reaction i'll play
with this what do you got all right
i'm working on this bit about how uh i'm
in my 30s
which is an interesting time to be in
your 30s because you get to watch old
people and young people hate each other
you know it's like [ __ ] you boomer
you're clueless and then the old people
are like
gen z is entitled and lazy and and uh
[ __ ] and all this everybody hates
everybody
yeah and i'm in the middle and i get to
watch i have my grandpa
and my nephew is like 14 13
and they're they fight all day but
they're similar
they're very similar they both sit at
home all day watching the news they both
uh have no muscle tone they're both like
victims they both count the the the
diversity
you know like my grandpa's like a lot of
black people in this show and my
nephew's like good diversity you know
and they bought that blue hair
there's a lot of similarities and then
hold on i wrote something down they
fight all the time and it's fascinating
to watch uh oh they both think
they're not doing enough like my
grandpa's like you kids don't go outside
you don't have to walk to school you
don't get jobs and my nephew is like
old people you ruined everything you
should be donating to this you should be
going out and helping they both think
they're not doing enough
and uh it's fascinating to watch them
the big punches like you kids are
[ __ ] you can't eat a peanut
and then the kid's like well i eat ass
you didn't do that
and then he's like well i was shot at
nam and he's like well i was shot out in
homeroom
so they're actually oh that's good
they're kind of the same but they fight
it's it could be something i wish i
didn't nominate
what was the line before that uh you
can't you're a [ __ ] you can't even eat
a peanut
you kids you know these days and he's
like well weed ass
so like we're we're the basically the
point is like they're both
tough just in different ways but they
don't see it
and they're actually quite similar
that's why they fight
you know what it seems like like the
kids the younger generation
is tough like almost involuntarily
like they had well nom you were like you
could kind of dodge a draft you can't
like dodge school
oh interesting you know i mean like it's
like four stars
that's an allergy right yeah it
they just they're born that way you
can't you can't interesting
there's something about like
both points are valid like i listen to
them i'm like this is fascinating
because like you're both making some
solid defense arguments but and then you
look at yourself and you're like i eat
peanuts and ass
oh that's good maybe i should bring it
back to me
yeah because it i'm in the middle and i
i almost because i have a bit about how
like there weren't school shootings
when i was in school yeah it was rare i
mean columbine was a huge deal that was
huge and then
uh i remember i have a bit where i say
you know it's a very different
bit but i say you know uh when i was in
school there weren't a lot of mass
shootings so every once in a while we
would poke a kid to see if he had it in
them you know
until i get into a bit but it's like but
there's something about
so you kind of missed the mass shootings
and nom like you're the most worthless
of all
oh that's the best oh interesting
maybe maybe it should be i don't need to
ask or peanuts
maybe that's funnier because you're the
made the bit is that you're most
worthless of all
you're like [ __ ] i missed the golf war
and i was too big a [ __ ] for iraq
yeah yeah yeah interesting
i missed both i missed it all yeah ah
do you think there's anything about them
being similar
yeah for sure i think they are similar
but they both like dealt with race riots
and stuff like there there
there's a lot of similarities with like
the 50s and 60s in the
2020s or whatever you call it
2000 teens
you know you both protested
yeah opposing sides right right
yeah they're both similar they are
they're very similar they both play the
victim like young kids are like
we have it so hard now with income
inequality and we can't afford this
and no one's paying us and then old
people are like i walked eight miles
uphill through the snow to get to school
you don't know what it was like yeah
when you were my age you owned a home
and they're like i also got shot at by
the [ __ ] vietnamese
yeah like every yeah it's a valid point
it's available for young people like
yeah life is harder now
in that way but we're also more
privileged we also have
we got uber eats you know like my uncle
my grandmother it is real hard right now
i do i do feel for young people where
it's like
but at the same time like this there's
air conditioning
we say it's worse but then look at what
[ __ ]
the vietnam generation exactly that's
why it's it's
you got drafted into an unwinnable war
insane
insane so yeah it's a fascinating
argument because they're both
making some solid points
and on paper i feel like people get you
know participation trophies you kids and
they're like
that wasn't my idea like quit yelling at
me yeah the [ __ ] they blame kids for is
like
it's kind of the fault of parents it's
really less
kids and parents should have done a
better job preparing them for failure
right parents parents don't understand
that
k like if your kid's crying at losing
that's okay that's part of life right
right they should be prepared to lose a
little in life
and they'll win at some point but like
if you get
beaten up too much by losing then you're
probably gonna
[ __ ] be a loser yeah if it's true i
mean like
ev it should hurt you as a kid like i
remember crying and losing sports as a
kid
like that's part of life you know
totally
you but that's it's we should kind of
it's necessary to learn
losing helps you someday win but i think
it
that sheltering [ __ ] some some young
people up i think
i think so for sure i think that's the
old person's grievance with the
participation
yeah but i also do think like see i'm in
between well i think inclusion is good
but i also think kids just being handed
[ __ ] is not great
i completely i kind of go back and forth
where it's like it's good to have to
work for stuff
because yes that's a good lesson for
life where like life is going to be hard
but then so i i with the participation
trophy it's like i like the angle of
like
what was my idea yeah yes i wanted to
earn it [ __ ] right
right yeah you that was you you're your
son's idea
who gets what kind of [ __ ] noble
person gets a participation trophy and
it's like
good for me yeah like we're not happy
with that [ __ ] either
i know right all right all right this is
a rich premise okay yours is much richer
than mine i mean i kind of threw some
[ __ ]
no no i like yours i like yours they
they don't have to be this
rich uh you know this is [ __ ]
delicious giant bit yeah does this not
become drinkable
too drinkable and i uh i got three spots
now because i three at the cellar
i just added one i'm [ __ ] back
i'm gonna plug some again uh yeah what
do you got here you got the phone
come out man three weeks
jesus hey so the 25th
but then the 25th this comes out so i
would have just
i would have just been to zane's i'll be
at lexington comedy of broadway the 5th
to 7th of august
albeit uh kansas city comedy club
uh in missouri the 12th through 14th
portland the 19th through 21st royal oak
comedy castle the 26th through 28th
boston laugh boston the second to 4th of
uh september the 9th to 11th i will be
at the atlanta punch line
great diner connection to it oh yeah
millersville pa
the 15th of september 16th through 19th
philly helium as good as it gets baby
let's [ __ ] dance
23rd through 20 or 22-25 moon tower
might add a little [ __ ] houston or
dallas action that week beforehand
look out on my [ __ ] social media and
the last week of the month i'll be in st
louis helium so
[ __ ] check it out samurail.com
shows hell yeah all right all right i'm
at uh speaking of helium i'm in
philadelphia this weekend
one of my all-time favorite does it get
any better than that room
love philly i love that town i love that
club i love the people
philly is [ __ ] special that farmers
market too right oh yeah
what's it called again reading terminal
is that it oh i don't know [ __ ] that is
that rittenhouse square
area or fish town i don't know but they
all blend together but i do
i love philly i have like a i have a
strong love for philadelphia
same they're good and they're good
people great people great crowds they're
smart but they don't get upset
so it's like the perfect it's a good mix
of blue collar but also white collar
yes they come together in like a
beautiful way yeah yeah that's a perfect
boston is similar boston's great buffalo
helium after that come out to buffalo
that's that's a fun town that's a town
that needs a laugh god damn it
then dayton funny bone appleton and
skyline arlington improv
texas brea improv out in orange county
albany hello
uh west palm beach comedy connection in
providence another great one
madison you get built at that trophy bed
in west palm beach
that's true uh madison wisconsin one of
the one of the all-time greats you're
there soon
zany's in nashville rochester i'm right
on your heels
richmond funny bone that could be tough
we're dancing brother portland helium
laughs boston
and uh yeah all kinds of fun stuff
uh vancouver hopefully
opens up by then vancouver's special man
what a city canada vancouver gets
not nearly enough love it's the might be
the prettiest city
in uh i don't know north america just
that sea wall remember we were there
together
oh yeah we did that festival thanks to
will hanley phil hanley set that up and
he just
toured the whole [ __ ] city to us yeah
what a special week you me carmen lynch
gary veeder
yeah joe list like you get what hanley's
so delicate because growing up there
you're like this is too pretty
you got no he was in oshawa he's a he
grew up originally in a suburb of
toronto so he actually
grew up in like an oil town oh really so
he it makes no sense why he is this like
from improper model all his friends are
like tough [ __ ]
town people oh that's again phil was
like this handsome [ __ ] model
yeah gorgeous model he used to wear
cardigans now he wears tie-dye i can't
figure him out the game of hippie
yeah follow phil hanley our buddy phil m
hanley on instagram great comic
killer comics great got a special in the
works gonna be dope and uh
yeah dude uh we'll plug that up we'll
plug it up
subscribe to the patreon patreon.com we
might be drunk pod
and man we just we got so much good
stuff coming keep your eyes
peeled for fat cat rye that shit's
coming dude
hell yeah you know you know what else is
very drinkable and goes down easy
this pod tell a friend spread the love
keep sharing it in studios you [ __ ]
rock matt
we love you doug yeah i mean [ __ ] this
is uh i just said dog sincerely that's
how hard this [ __ ] goes down
i meant it we love you fam we're
you're on the ground floor by the way
get snap your fingers and this is going
to be a
bar with a whole setting
we got a guy a mixologist or whatever
the hell you want to call it a bartender
i like the idea of having special guest
bartenders too oh that'd be great you're
a bartender like [ __ ] call in and be
on this show make a sh
i like that too i like bringing drinks
every once in a while but having a
bartender here would be
crazy hell yeah great idea and uh we're
gonna get some guests on eventually we
just gotta we're
we're fine tuning and hand picking so uh
yeah email us
send us stuff rexp we might be drunkpod
gmail.com all right keep on drinking
very drinkable we might be drunk
we might be drunk as
long as we are hanging out you know we
might be drunk
raise a glass let's talk [ __ ] head peeps
wrecks and a bit
may be drunk we might be
drunk